life's pretty uneventful for sweetie a
seven-year-old panda who spends most of
her time eating she may look relaxed but
sweetie and her mate sunshine are about
to embark on a 5,000 mile journey on
Sunday they'll leave behind everything
they know in the misty mountains of
Sichuan for their new home in the end
Razoo there are many here in China
who'll miss them more than the man who's
raised them from birth oh you a time
shall usher will you jungle I've looked
after them since they were living in so
it will be painful being separated from
them anyways over though I try to stay
in touch by telephone and email the
Panda loan from the Chinese government
will cost 600,000 pounds a year plus
another 70,000 in imported bamboo these
two chopped through more than a thousand
kilograms of it a month and only the
best will do for China's national
treasure the zoo says it'll recoup its
costs through ticket sales and what
would really draw the crowds is the
pitter-patter of little paws sunshine
and sweetie are both of breeding age and
the hope is that while they're in
Edinburgh they'll have a cub like one of
these but it won't be easy female pandas
are only in heat for two days a year and
the male's suffer from low libido but
perhaps the cold nights in Scotland will
bring them closer together we decided to
warm sunshine up to the idea with some
caledonian mood music
these things take time but if Edward
does spark some passion for sunshine and
sweetie their baby would be the first
panda cub ever born in Britain Holly
Williams Sky News beef on CR China